[Music]
is of everybody happy Thursday how's it
going morning good morning a good
morning it is indeed because the Kingdom
Hearts 3 DLC the remind that is now
available on ps4 rima I saw on our
article on our website mentioned that
Xbox one users will not have access
until February 25th long time ps4 games
so we will be playing on ps4 today
because you know it's here here and I
gotta play it so boom there we go
yeah and yeah
all right that was just like the the
splash screen the opening so here we go
starting it up I will go with this save
of mine so I could be wrong but
sorry guys I'm moving really fast and in
this cuz I'm actually just really
excited to play it but yeah morning - oh
yes I think that you have to beat the
game to play this part okay you'll see
okay let me that's fair you gotta know
how it ends
how Kingdom Hearts 3 ends exactly just
as a heads up so before I press continue
let me just say hello to those in the
chat Christian Scott flange ray woo that
was you know I probably pronounced that
wrong toxic gave me cool max town
Gabriele hello everyone I wanted to say
hi before I get 1 million percent
immersed into the game alright let's
check it out I mean we can't exactly
spoiler alert this is post the full game
if you have not played Kingdom Hearts 3
it's going to be spoilers here and yeah
let's do it I'm excited expect there to
be a lot of cutscenes but I'm not
skipping anything today letting you guys
know let's go
I will snap
may your heart be your guiding key
[Music]
picture this a black goat stashes away a
letter then orders a white goat to
search for it what could his intentions
possibly be
great a riddle just what I need surely
there are many possibilities perhaps he
forgot where it's hidden or he's playing
a prank or the letter has truly gone
missing I can think of several reasons
of hand guessing is simply useless well
then just follow your orders plain and
simple
[Music]
yes that's what I've always done
I followed the orders from above without
question however I sometimes can't help
but read into my opponents strategy too
long on the job if the contents of the
box are so unknown why is it of such
critical importance to the organization
furthermore was it Zaire notes or xemnas
who gave the order well it's tricky
all Zainul cares about is the clash
between the seven lights and thirteen
darknesses it's unlikely he would hold
such an interest in this mysterious box
which means the order was issued by
xemnas or the one who informed me of my
task you as if it must have been
sameness my inquiries suggested
otherwise
oh man you asked him what are your
intentions look I don't know what's
inside the box but it's been protected
by Keyblade wielders since way back when
aren't you curious I heard it contains
information that's vital to all Keyblade
wielders secrets and where did you hear
this I don't remember I keep my eyes and
ears wide open but I've traveled so many
different places it's hard to keep
everything straight you know if this box
is truly as important as you say why now
I believe you discovered that others
also seek it and you need to find it
before anyone else does in order to keep
your connection to the Box a secret from
those around you
Zig bah who are you really
no matter it doesn't make a difference
to me it's all the same I'm content to
feign ignorance the question is who are
you
Luke surd who are you things are getting
tense yeah I mean it is gonna be a lot
of cutscenes
I feel like three had so many more
cutscenes and like one and two but it's
nice it's pretty it looks good it does
it's finally over
I'm sure making a No
we'll find Kyrie let's head back to
master yen SID
we can figure it out no I know what to
do
Sora my whole journey began the day I
lost her and every time I find her she
slips away again I thought we'd finally
be together but she's out there alone
not for one more second that's right
squad yeah Thank You Donald goofy but
this time I have to go it alone Sora
listen the power of waking isn't a go
chase hearts around even if you do
locate Kyrie that you might never come
home to us again I will and we'll both
be back before you know it please let
him go
Mickey Riku his heart and his mind are
made up now believe in him yeah safe
journey Sora thank you
Sora is basically like Mario and Peach
they never really fully reconnect
[Music]
piercing into my soul all right so you
know on the road again shut up yep
oof let's see where it starts you up oh
here we go looks like an episode of
Dragon Ball Z what's up chat thanks for
tuning in opening up the new DLC here
add some cutscenes plenty of them
[Music]
the sound of the letters yeah
so yeah
it Ward's off darkness it's useful
toldja
and so how'd it go the tour
I learned the reason for my existence Oh
tell me more the world people live
seemingly peaceful lives they believe
themselves to be moral and virtuous but
it's all an act
no young Simon what do darkness lurks in
the foot of everyone's heart their light
is a total farce
sounds like your trip around the world
opened your eyes but you got a little
bit more than you anticipated you must
have seen a lot of darkness those who
are weak and who desire greater power
simply strip the strong of their power
and convinced themselves they've earned
it that's how people become tainted by
darkness they believe what they want to
believe using hollow reasons as
justification they repeat this cycle and
their darkness grows so you're saying
the weak feel the need to justify their
actions to maintain a sense of self
can't let that slide
no it's better they be ruled by darkness
people carry delusions of having power
but it's a lie
they are but sheep pretending to be
wolves no Eric meant I can understand
why oh never heard that one before
a keyblade wielder willing to side with
the darkness why not just let them be
until the darkness consumes them because
left alone the world would fall to chaos
there needs to be order
you sure about that why not just sit
back and watch a play out understanding
hearts is difficult more so the emotions
within I simply realized that it's easy
to dismiss what you don't comprehend all
right all right
the world needs you grant you that one I
don't know what I can do but I will act
what comes next is too important
I suppose letting false light dictate
the future might be a pretty lousy move
so you can make a change you have that
power what do you want for the world
power hey who knows my trainings coming
to an end and the exams not far off
maybe I can gain some clarity then
you're letting the exam decide listen to
me the results don't matter you believe
the world needs you sounds like you
already know where you're headed it's
funny somehow a consents where I'm
supposed to go and what I'm supposed to
do
yes
even this coat there's something
familiar about it as if I meant to wear
this no you'll ditch it soon what do you
mean I mean that one day you're going to
outgrow it how so
if you truly possess great power the
darkness can't control you you won't
need a silly old coat to stay safe in
fact you'll be the one controlling the
darkness instead me on the other hand
I'm too much of a scaredy can't ever
take mine yeah who are you really
some kind of fortune-teller
well I could lie tell you that's what I
am when I'm actually a brilliant artist
or even a scholar I could tell you that
I dream of world peace when I'm actually
planning for its destruction the truth
is what you see with your eyes not what
you hear
so your name I guess there's no harm
my name is censored by the late yeah
[Music]
I'm a lost master
[Music]
lost master may your heart be a guiding
key oh we gonna get another cut see ya
damn probably lots one Zack I know I
know
Oh 7e baby is laid there but so funny
old man mind sharing with us
[Music]
I stand here today because I love you
hated encounter read his mind very many
years ago when I was still young lad I
never learned who he was there perhaps I
never will but I see now the truth he
spoke of Sara we don't have time for
bedtime stories without the kid we're
still down a thirteenth vessel and as
for the other 12 only three of us are
here right now are you absolutely sure
the others made their way back to their
respective times yo what up Bob Jones
welcome back
malucia and lark scene are both here in
this time attempting to locate the new
seven hearts luke surd is also somewhere
about in this age but after our last
meeting he went in search of something
per your order isn't that so huh oh that
right well let's just say that what he's
doing will benefit us in the long run
but it's really of no importance right
two-second go on playing your cards
close as usual
[Music]
all right the hearts of Ansan resembles
Vanitas riku replica and youngjae
annoyed returned to where they came from
and reassembled once more each of them
is seeking a guardian of light this is
my favorite so the ones who turn human
and then back again
nobodies are me you Luke surd
malucia and lark scene that's five the
ones from the past transferred into
replicas are Ansem xemnas Vanitas Riku
replicas and the old man's younger six
bony band we had the old man in the
total comes up to eleven he's basically
I think we're still missing but now we
must discuss why assemble here today
Mayan carnations from past times vessels
into which I transferred my heart my
essence were destroyed thus I was
restored to what you see now for one who
completely disappear their heart and
body must be restored to their original
form that is one reason why I
distributed my heart into several
vessels and summons him this originated
from terror or rather his young form and
it too was restored however my heart has
returned to me on his is yet lost I
decided to fill this hollow vessel with
my heart indeed same heart had
previously resided with him young Terra
it is Christopher Lloyd so that makes 12
20 replicas were created by Vexen the
first 12 were nothing more than puppets
barely human the prototype model was the
that leaves us with six and some Ximena
starts five vessels one left vex in
endemics are candidates but backups at
best the plan for the last replica is to
give it a heart that is connected to
Sora's connected to Sora anyone in mind
the second prototype that was created
number I tho erased from memory it
remained in Beck since records its
existence is greatly linked to Sora's
memories and thus should prove to be
more than adequate for our needs
number I an imaginary number of fitting
while Young's a note is occupied with
transferring hearts
I must go fulfill my duty I will go and
retrieve Vexen reliable as always it
sounds to me like you've got everything
dependably under control well I'm off to
do my part the plan as we agreed upon
all right let's do it let's get er done
come where is Mickey the mouse
like the first cutscene yeah yeah your
heart be your guiding key yes the second
time we've heard that your heart
Wow alright we are like 18 minutes into
the stream a beautiful movie I feel like
games nowadays you have to have time set
to sit down and play Kingdom Hearts game
yeah we back this is
[Music]
you didn't finish so they've just heard
the end charity back so soon what's
wrong well where do I begin even with
the power of waking you can't just bring
someone back but Kyra's heart hasn't
been lost yet she's still with us right
maybe but this time I'm afraid the
situation is a lot worse hey I've
already restored six hearts what's one
more but that's not how it's supposed to
work at all the power of waking is meant
to be used to wake and restore sleeping
hearts not to restore them after they've
completely faded away from existence
you've done that six times before and as
a result you've managed to greatly alter
the course of history itself you've
broken a nature taboo nature a forbidden
act break a taboo of nature and you'll
end up paying an extraordinary price
I've heard that before so what's the
price you'll lose your powers you won't
be able to use the power of waking
that's all no problem but that's not all
you yourself will vanish from this world
and without your powers you can't return
to the world you came from
I don't care there's a lot I don't
understand but I know that this is all I
can do right now I have to do everything
I can to get Kyrie back that's the whole
reason behind my journey I can't stop
you can I nope I have to follow my heart
hmm well then this really is goodbye so
listen carefully to me hmm
you'll return to the Past again but you
won't be able to rewrite it this time no
matter what happens you have to accept
it and move on okay you are in control
oh my goodness all right we've got some
new abilities so let's just go all right
let's go
the heart you have now it already
existed during that time it went back
into that past earlier nothing can
change that fact the place where you'll
return is the tear in the fabric of time
that was created when you changed your
destiny then changed it once again in
order to not stray too far from the true
power of waking don't enter and pass
through the hearts of the Guardians
until you reach Kyra's heart every
emotion that each of the guardians felt
anxiety you're not him fear kindness
everything they saw and everything that
they felt then you'll clear away through
it Traverse across their hearts and dive
ever deeper inside I can't be sure
what's waiting for you at the end or
what you'll actually be able to do but
by following the connection of hearts
what you'll come to discover a greater
truth 13:1 that's sure hope you will be
torn heart from body but in this flow of
time in the past you'll only have up
until the moment you left for this place
so you'll have to find and restore
kairi's heart before then okay that's
all the advice I can give you so now
we're at I can only say
be your guiding key all right that's
three times deep on the fat mother he's
filing it's a moon all right so now
we're Harry Potter and The Avengers mix
again you know fix the fabric of time by
going back and then we all get it
Centauri is a it's all right got it got
a dive to the heart broski fun the Laura
is very concise Brian you're right what
did you pur
last reminds either one
who are you your heart man never mind
darkness Vanitas
let me Adam all right finally first
battle I'll see you let's go
because my warmup don't judge me too
hard pull push see what we got here are
we doing chat we made it
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I start
did like the same move on you
[Music]
oh my god I can't read that
[Music]
my warmup yeah I'm still remembering I
just spent 20 minutes and cuts am I
gonna remember actually I shouldn't
start with this key player what were you
using I'm using my own miss bellboy it's
the one from the Pirates of the
Caribbean Sea
can you really
hey to your crap
yeah
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
I didn't get
[Music]
[Music]
there you go
that's that same dog
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there you go here we go
[Music]
[Music]
mm
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Music]
I definitely needed some time to reboot
my senses that's what that was for
that's what this board that whole match
he didn't break dang who I'm not even
playing my hands are like gripping
he's ascending like golden feathers
unleash the beast
done
oh good step out
it's Donald okay though that gonna take
a nap is this aquas heart ven's heart
was so peaceful
but this
this is beer I mean she's been through
some things you know yeah play two
points beauty medal
pull it together Sora we haven't lost
them they still have their hearts but we
have to protect them right
we stand together Mickey
Kairi goofy watch the others
normal we should all get to safety while
we still can
it's too late for that can we sit down
up face down someone help
oh let me Adam did it
it can't be No
who
they always make the dark versions of
the characters so cool-looking that yeah
so this is the fear and despair that
aqua feels bad times and now I feel it
too okay he really is glowing like a
super saiyan god super all right next
battle inbound oh it's time
oh here again
oh no she's like square up no I don't
want to square up with you
[Music]
ha
[Music]
my god
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
I was a great name disappeared
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
last one
bingo
the airship it's like one of my favorite
[Music]
I miss offers like you guys are children
[Applause]
I'll always remember the lakiya
Canyon right side clean they were
introduced
[Music]
my finisher so exciting
[Music]
see the plastic
[Music]
yeah sorry aqua that was significantly
easier than the first one Home Slice
asked that attempt that's foam boy
[Music]
that's the reaction I would expect Mario
to have whenever a peach gets snatched
again happens way more to him I'm sorry
oh no sorry that it rough he just wants
to be with his boot mm-hmm they shared
the fruit then Terra we found you
Terra please say you're in there
what gives aqua I know that you're not
him
now let our friends oh oh did I did I
pass through the tear Oh
Zhora nómine what are you doing here
have you lost yourself like I did well
it's a long story but tell me why
haven't you returned to Kyra's heart yet
he is their 13th today is the day you
all lose what before you even face the
13 every last one of you will be torn
heart from body but fear not the
Keyblade will still be forged because
I'm still not able to but I'm calling
out to Terra's heart and I brought him
here
Terra no Terra's heart is too steeped in
darkness instead I've brought out
Terra's most personal and powerful
thoughts oh boy
this is terras sadness anger lament
terrorist thoughts we're not gonna lose
to you
oh there we go yourself who are you you
got you the same
pretty cool armor though yeah I remember
seeing that armor T's so long ago and
the Keyblade Wars impossible like who is
that guy manifestation iris we thought
for this moment
[Music]
Oh
Yetta Mindy
[Music]
I think in the actual game into can't
even see em they're displayed hey they
look like Bahrain there Richard spirit
as long as master Z naught resides
within you you're a threat to Aqua
inventor
you would give your life for theirs
you must be removed from existence at
all costs
this isn't free no
guys like it like a $30 reason and then
I think like a $40
Wow Domini
can you call out to Tara no his rage is
too strong respond tonight
yeah yeah no matter who gets hurt it's
bad for Tara either way you have to
leave go to the world of ocean and sky
and you I got this in it there's that
smile
[Music]
cheater
[Laughter]
begone
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you'll be gone bro how can you be here
hey I can travel the different times to
unite did you think you were the only
one with that power you dare
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah seeing that you have also taken the
forbidden path you too must be ready to
make the ultimate sacrifice got your
pirate or what else let's go
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nobody's
Oh
I was trying to heal myself can't heal
you're being juggled like that oh my god
stupid little lasers I know I was being
greedy I'd love to see Sauron smash
nice
all of these
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
over
don't worry
[Music]
here we go Hugo I like that
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
it's gonna get ugly pleasure I know
thank you
[Music]
over here
[Music]
[Music]
Wow there's a word you
I know what about and then BOOM
nope said darkness awaits you like the
screen good fight though
you got him slate takes a little while
for me to like memories patterns but oh
nice all right
Wow and also like the dodge in this game
is not like it's not like like the air
dodge or the roll like it comes out
whenever like if you're in the middle of
pressing like a button or something
you'll wait until that move is done so
you kind of got it like chop up your
strings a little bit but I do need
[Music]
[Music]
you're all alone no Gubbio Dolan
stocking wish it were that easy
he's made a crab bisque
[Music]
[Music]
that's for good measure
yep you're all stocked up but yeah but
Dodge is still super good but yeah like
sometimes I'll be like oh no I committed
too heavily to a strings cumin is good
though 9 out of 10 icing for strength
yeah I leveled up some of these yeah see
like this one's higher than this yeah
I think I was loved one all three of
these ones up actually I felt then they
change some things I think I heard there
was like an update and maintain 50
[Music]
King Mickey's got this under control go
hang out with the boy Riku when do we
see Final Fantasy characters not sure
yet we started it along with you guys
this is new to us kou they're both gonna
[Music]
leave it to me
Wow
hurry
I see what happened
Oh a mid-fight cutscene I love you so
much powering up
it's a Yeti Cuban weight
yeah we barely got started where are you
going
that's you right there Riku real star
worries up in here
hey let's speed it up keep the line
moving let's go
someone your own side
Oh
bill
[Music]
take this
by let's make it interesting
Hey
here's a lot of a good
[Music]
nice
one down
what does that end it
so I gotta take out Riku Shadow reach
replica Riku excuse me
Riku replica whatever you think you have
the edge I'm cheating you if you didn't
spend the majority of it upside down
right Akeno you different like you're
actually worthy to use one what do you
mean the old coot promised to bequeath
me his why else do you think I would
ever put up with all his nonsense it'd
be wasted on you
[Music]
oh whoops forgot my weapons
[Music]
yo
[Music]
[Music]
you forgot about the users
where we can
you
[Music]
[Music]
okay
I got lost for a second
Sweeney riku's in here
and I'm with you he's like I don't buy
it for a second you can teleport yeah
exactly
anybody who dies by like falling off a
cliff there never did secretly alive oh
well you defeated a child I'm not real
you're not bro I'm the real one aren't
you my past self from when Anson
possessed me No a third beat Ansem and
you're still here this guy is me
Oh
I knew it it's a replica
a soon-to-be empty vessel I've been
waiting for a chance like this yeah
Ewing
spookie was like a mannequin yeah
Hey what are you doing take the vessel
No the world already has you know
there's someone else who needs the
replica more you know nominate you're
saving her
[Music]
oh and I love the flashbacks equal to
the old graphics - and everything
they're so good
good luck
a little confused up to this frame
because I feel like a lot of this was in
the main story I'm trying to remember
like exactly what I what I saw in the
story if they added on to it they
might've added on to it like certain
parts they're reminding perfect any be
in the chat I have no idea what's
happening I know the story
if you're jumping in the kingdom right
it's like starting now it's not gonna
make any sense whatsoever it's really
hard to keep up with and they're still
games like a few is a replica for
nominating yeah wish we could help her
now but first okay I'll go help the
others oh yeah the other ally had like
Mickey fighting off everyone to King
Mickey's every day hmm
I'll be back after all of this is over
hey I thought you'd be gone by now
uh-huh water boy you're the organization
whoa chill out I'm not here to fight I
promise listen names demyx it's a long
story but I'm sorta on your side oh
right here see all the cool kids have
one right ienzo got me this enough proof
for you no no why are you here I'm a top
secret mission apparently they're
looking to find themselves another
replica I heard a rumor that I could
maybe find one here from Zechs uh uh
ienzo so I've just been killing time
yeah yeah where should I get that
haircut you sure you know what you're
doing don't worry about it not to brag
but I've done this before that's not
just an empty vessel memories but
promise me you'll be careful with it
deliver it safely okay I see I see
yeah I knew you could play as
metacharacters but I see that they are
adding on to the cutscenes at first I
was like Solnit a says he has a phone
therefore he must be
[Music]
you when the I was playing through the
main story I would sit and watch this
just to see how unique the animation was
and you'll notice like after a certain
amount of time they'll run off to the
side and it will reset the fighting
animation so what you need to fight it
yeah where do y'all even need me does he
just finish him off
oh no furs it go home now going boy
we're just putting out a bunch of fires
today huh yeah you know you're only one
guy yo click King Mickey and snacks your
majesty
no he just goes was still glorious
controller tonight
all right
[Music]
yeah
it would be cool to play okay here we go
mid-fight cut see you weren't kidding
they love it charged up now their SSD
all right exactly what I need it
that one does too much
[Music]
no surah one final game the rules are
simple all you have to do to win is find
me among these cards and strike me down
you play too much gotta save my girl Bob
Jones says I'll get you out
[Music]
the game continues
[Music]
over here
it's gone
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
whoa now you lose without interruption
please
like sorry guys I'm trying to find you
boss
Oh an aeroplane pewpewpew pick up you
were born for these sorts of games no
thanks don't what's this a wild card
you've earned it
oh that hang on to it could turn the
tables you had a really small health bar
play you again someday when we're just
guys one we're just getting up I should
like that very much
Sora
Sora is so wholesome
yeah after defeating the enemies like
maybe we'll hang out someday yeah he
gets it hasten change Thanks it's Persia
good or is this normal mode there's a
lot going on
oh yeah Valley make water
that's why the first I had a small
health bar VCF regular
[Music]
trying keep layers
what a fun thing to take
what's your framerate it looked really
smooth I couldn't say for sure cuz the
ps4 doesn't have a Oh Frank counter so
now it all comes back to me I think a
little whooping hey is that a real laugh
yes my heart is remembering how to feel
really that's good and now I am on the
cusp of reclaiming my identity my
purpose for being thanks to you Sora
but this fight wasn't in three are like
a part of
[Music]
quick big quick work of that
Bob Chung and said looks like you got
your warmup now let's dying yes I'm
Charlie Koh this it's not to die so we
can get through this I really want to
play Kyrie and it's not looking like
we're gonna make it
[Music]
but you're gonna be completed you're
good
I didn't ask you for your garbage
opinion I lost to a bunch of losers like
you rekt but could be worse become that
geezers heart tank no thanks
then why help him I was really just
along for the ride with
my secret
more question yep Sora I'll go after
xemnas while you go find the others oh
then Mickey's hoodie has ear pocket they
sell those at Disneyland where they did
for a while
[Music]
the sun's going down that's what you're
thinking of right now killing it Persia
it's Lena slaying the whole organization
there we go look closely that's not
terribly would you quit calling out but
I'm still going to keep calling his name
we have to light his way home then hey
guys feeling a little left out here
venetus you're coming home to chill out
Daft Punk boy huh huh but my home is in
you you know what'll happen right I'll
just disappear inside of you forever
don't you have any love it all for your
own brother we're not brothers
we're the same huh you believe that then
you really are naive huh this may shock
you but we're not the same like you
think I was just hidden deep inside of
you for a really long time
all Zayin or did was tear me right out
of you then go back to where you came
from hmm make me such complex if it's
darkness you're looking for Aventis then
I have more than enough to go around
stop quit using our friend for your
games
a keyblade master wielding your key in
anger
shameful we have unfinished business I
fell into darkness and for ten years I
wandered through the dark realm
now I'm finally here and I want only one
thing with all my heart
sayin or I'm casting you out of Tara
forever
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
on that Elsa
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
yeah he's not you got not
there you go
[Music]
okay I was like when's the mid-fight
cousin gonna get here before I use all
my mana aqua yeah square up all right
now y'all are in trouble I will end this
here and now I think we get to choose
[Music]
you wish
[Music]
nope dark times
don't let it escape they'll break Jim
[Music]
right
break him joy the shadow
during the shadows you know
[Music]
let's go
did very good
I got scared there I was getting juggled
yeah a little bit but you gonna king she
say this PLC is worth the 30 bucks
Persia I mean we're having a good time
I would say so far I mean uh no reason
why I wanted to play the best but I
wanted to play as batteries so when
we're not there we're not there yet
I mean this
[Music]
down here
hey go good hit
yep
the bigness of deep sorrow for you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Toy Story I like to throw so much that
I've just been using this camera really
it's really cool
[Music]
bummer that this wasn't launched the
same damn Xbox have that exhibit E or
Playstation you know at first it was
four years yeah you're right
what's a month right exactly
your face amrohi's Aventis that was
taken away and your the peace ventus
needed to be whole again so why
shouldn't you and i look exactly the
same you define me sora the same way
that Ventus does we are brothers who
together make a greater whole then why
won't you stand by our side instead of
with darkness because i am darkness and
i do stand by your side i'm the shadow
that you cast oh how much closer could i
be so many metaphors i know but i didn't
but i didn't ask for this to be sifted
apart nice and neat we should be free to
choose not just light not just darkness
we decide what we are
but Ventus I did decide who I am you see
and what you are is darkness
[Music]
what I am is darkness noted he's
darkness he gave confirm wait well is he
okay yeah how is that okay
Benitez yeah I don't think I'll talk him
out of being darkness
drinking games take us out whenever they
mentioned heart or darkness three would
be over just die then Tara please come
back yeah yeah Gero your friends are
here
no you'll never be able to break these
chains amis there our bonds
jeez
farewell
hmm Tara I kept my promise
[Music]
I like
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I will not be silenced one day one
day this right I will return to this
land
[Music]
you can protect my friends
Tara now
[Music]
aqua and vin missed all that i like how
when surah turned into heartless he was
just one of like the little pleb ones
and then when Tara tannins and re Liz
he's like whoa happened to me I left out
of terrorist thoughts and we fought
saying or together
that's it
this is Tara's heart he must have
protected me Tara
is it you Susie blitzball they have a
game right never stop and then lighting
went way back you're here I heard you
two then you found me just like you
promised
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
aqua and Ventus need rest
Terra look after them no Sora I'm going
to that's what he wants for us to make a
mistake put ourselves in danger so go
we'll catch up with you right I got this
word I got this next time yeah all right
you guys wait can I see yeah yeah well
thank you guys so much for tuning in we
are over time now however I'm definitely
gonna be playing more of this I want to
see the rest I wanna play as Kyrie I'm
actually so salty that we did not get to
play as her but I'm refreshing it's fair
I would assume that they would not make
her like the first character all right I
get it
fine ya got me I'll be playing more but
anyways thank you guys so much for
tuning in if you enjoyed what you saw
then the DLC is now available on ps4 the
cheapest bundle is like 30 bucks there's
like a more special bundle that comes
with some it comes with some extra
content
yeah the Xbox one comes out next month
yes and next month Xbox one
well happy February 25th thank you so
much for tuning in every weekday at 11
a.m. Pacific time you can catch us right
here on the GameSpot YouTube channel so
if you'd you know aren't as much of
Kingdom Hearts fans don't worry because
every day we play something different so
come back next time and we'll see you
then bye
you
[Music]
you
[Music]